eu quero fazer três registros muito
breves o tema que me foi proposto e eu
quero começar por uma experiência
pessoal a a mais traumática a mais
violenta a mais traumatizante
a mais dolorosa experiência de
discriminação racial que eu vivi
foi no âmbito escolar e é impressionante
porque em uma escola pública em que o
estado deveria zelar pela incolumidade
psíquica e física e moral da criança eu
fui vítima da experiência mais
traumatizante e é uma experiência que
tem a ver com junção adversativa houve
um furto na escola ea professora de
português
bem no estilo do seu posto racismo
cordial
eu não entendi a época que isso esta era
dimensão cordial do racismo nem ver
alguns anos pra entender porque eu tinha
12 anos
mas ela disse houve um furto todos estão
sabendo
numa sala contígua à sala da diretora e
ela disse eu não quero acusar ninguém
mas e foi aí que eu aprendi
antes de ler as sentenças que depois das
conjunções adversativas sempre tem a
tragédia no haiti todavia entretanto
parecia que estava indo tão bem
ela disse eu não quero acusar ninguém
mais pra mim na sua modesta opinião os
autores do furto foram a ou b
a iberostar únicos pretinhos da sala era
eu
hédio silva júnior eo a depois dessa
experiência a mais do topo e essa
experiência me ocorreu
alguns segundos antes de ocupar a
tribuna do supremo tribunal federal
alguns anos defendeu as cotas para preto
na educação superior
eu tive a honra de ser escolhido o
advogado preto do movimento negro silva
no interior de minas gerais que foi peão
de obra até aos 16 anos família
estruturada chega em são paulo como se
diz em minas com uma mão atrás e outra
na frente
emir em direito mestrado e doutorado
publicou livros estudou no interior
morou fora do país o escolhido para
fazer a defesa das cotas e eu fiquei
pensando o que é que eu digo dos
ministros da nossa mais alta corte sobre
as cotas porque o pensamento corrente o
pensamento comum era que os pretos
ao invés de se esforçar queriam tavam
pois a usando de coitadismo 80
coitadinhos não é
daí surgiu a expressão coitadismo
os pretos ao invés de se esforçarem
estavam pousando de vítimas
culpabilizando o sistema pelo seu
próprio fracasso pelo seu fracasso
individual e pelo seu fracasso coletivo
e ao invés de investirem num esforço
pessoal queria uma esmola estatal nas
molas estatal e eu tive tinha duas
experiências muito interessantes que me
levavam a questionar essas assertivas a
primeira experiência aqui no curso de
direito do largo são francisco avião
mais pretos oriundos de países africanos
do que pretos brasileiros integram a
chapa tem um problema e porque na
educação superior preto pode ser lixeiro
com toda com toda a dignidade dessas
ocupações
com todo respeito que essas ocupações
merecem porque que na educação pública
preto só pode ser faxineiro cozinheiro
bedell o lixeiro porque que a faculdade
de direito da universidade são francisco
tinha mais alunos a free anos do que é
preto os brasileiros como é que isto não
incomodava a sociedade brasileira
ou eu concluí a que os pretos são
geneticamente incapazes de acessar a
educação superior ou abrir a
possibilidade de que o modo de seleção
chamado vestibular era um instrumento
problemático e era ea história comprovou
que era e eu poderia que em porto na luz
com uma série de dados mas você está só
um
o sistema de cotas ampliou
exponencialmente o número de brancos
pobres na educação superior não só preço
é bom dar uma olhada nas estatísticas
nos resultados das ações afirmativas
antes de termos críticas nunca entrou
tanto o branco pobre na educação
superior quanto entrou depois das ações
afirmativas o segundo questionamento é
que os africanos que ingressavam pelo
sistema de cotas não prestavam
vestibular vinham pra cá por convênios
que o brasil mantinha com o país
africano e tinha o mesmo desempenho dos
seus colegas bancos brasileiros ou seja
o que qual era um dos problemas da
crença que havia antes das cotas no
acesso à educação superior
o de que a ideia de meritocracia cimi
dia fora da sala de aula quando há
mérito cras ia você mede em sala de aula
quem aqui atua no magistério do ensino
superior
sabe que um aluno pode passar no 200º
lugar ele não passou em primeiro lugar
no vestibular se que passou em 200º pode
ter em sala de aula o desempenho melhor
do que o que entrou em primeiro lugar
portanto não é a nota que se obtém na
antessala do vestibular que determina o
desempenho que se tem em sala de aula
infelizmente a história demonstrou que
nós estávamos corretos
quem hoje se debruça sobre o resultado
das chamadas ações afirmativas no acesso
à educação superior
vai ver que
os cursos de elite como medicina eito
etc
os alunos negros com toda a dificuldade
da educação com todos os problemas e as
mazelas que a educação básica pública
brasileira tem ingresso na educação
superior pela porta das cotas e tem o
mesmo o melhor desempenho de pitico que
frequentar a educação básica e escola
particular e esses alunos que vêm das
favelas que vem das palafitas que vem
das comunidades que a família fala com
erros de português e ele quando começa a
falar corretamente em casa é alvo de
exclusão
esse aluno não chega na universidade a
bordo de carros importados
esse aluno não chega na universidade
escoltado por motos e carros blindados
esse aluno muitas vezes não chega na
universidade com um recurso para fazer
três refeições diárias que a organização
mundial de saúde recomenda mas ainda
assim ainda lutando contra adversidades
brutais
ele apresenta o mesmo desempenho do seu
colega eu quero finalizar portanto
começar finalizar portanto que esse
relógio é implacável e eles apoiem o
relógio aqui de maneira que você não tem
como evitar o relógio esses alunos estão
demonstrando que ações afirmativas fazem
com que a universidade
notem que a etimologia da palavra
universidade remete à universalidade
esses alunos pretos pobres
miseráveis da comunidade estão
demonstrando por brasil que a
universidade pode ser de fato a
universalidade e mais esses alunos estão
unificando o brasil porque às vezes eu
escuto notícias de que as ações
afirmativas devidem o brasil quem divide
o brasil é o racismo brasileiro e muitos
aqui já podem ter frequentado
restaurante de classe média
o restaurante de elite não é
impressionante que em restaurante de
classe média
o restaurante de elite não haja garçons
pretos que alguém pode falar não estudou
não fez a educação superior e tal não
tem preparo para ser o diretor da
empresa mas pra ser garçom não pode para
ser recepcionista não pode para ser
comissária de bordo não pode então essa
história de que está excluído porque não
tem preparo é uma falácia
não está excluído porque existe uma
coisa chamada privilégio racial em
alguns lugares só cabe branco no brasil
e eu fui o único preto até hoje até a
honra de sentar na cadeira de secretário
de estado da justiça
foi uma comoção de preto sentado na
cadeira e nós fomos à posse no supremo
tribunal federal isso entre 2005 e 2006
fomos proposta do ministro ricardo
lewandowski
e olha que o joaquinzão já era ministro
do supremo já que joão jardim isso pra
eu nessa oportunidade sempre uso único
terno importado que eu tenho que é um
carneiro e propaganda anos
imune ciei do meu terno importado
o único sapato importado também que eu
tenho para um cafezinho anos
cheguei em brasília a bordo do jatinho
do governo do estado com o governador do
estado o vice-governador do estado o
conselheiro do cnj época alexandre de
moraes hoje ministro do supremo tribunal
federal
o ajudante de ordens do governador e eu
a posse do meu ex professor ricardo
lewandowski passou o governador passa o
vice governador passou o conselheiro do
cnj
e aí vou passar eu para falar das
autoridades
veja o que eu era secretário de estado
doutor em direito com livros publicados
terno importado sapato importado mas o
segurança preto botou a mão no meu peito
e disse com licença e disse negrão a
sala dos seguranças ele não é um
problema dele da minha compleição física
de segurança não é o problema dele ter
conhecido tanto os pretos segurança
particular é ele não supor
mesmo com a presença do joaquinzão a
preto de último tom que eu pudesse ser
qualquer outra coisa que não fosse
segurança
a raiz da intolerância e do preconceito
está exatamente nesse componente afetivo
eu fui casado 16 já acabou
eu não vou fazer um plebiscito em mas eu
vou mesmo finalizar
é um sinal para o paparazzo ou alguém tá
bravo comigo eu fui casado durante 16
anos com a psicóloga então a cabeça no
trauma batizado pelas psicólogas e fiz
terapia durante alguns anos ainda faz e
aprende o valor de você falar sobre
sentimentos sobre valores sobre
ideologia sobre o corpo
sobre a experiência quando nós repetimos
a frase do mandela de que ninguém nasce
odiando de que as pessoas aprendem
socialmente odiah e portanto podem
aprender socialmente amar
a pergunta é o que é que eu estou
fazendo no meu lugar
crianças e nossos adultos aprendam a
amar um ao outro a despeito do outro ser
diferente de mim
o problema está na associação e
diferença e em inferioridade a palavra
da professora de português define o
destino dos dois alunos que não voltou
mais para a escola e outro que
aproveitou essa experiência para virar
militante do movimento negro estudar
sobre racismo fazer academia e está hoje
em porto nando vocês aqui mas talvez o
aprendizado não precise não precisa
necessariamente ser tão doloroso quanto
foi esse meu aprendizado
pessoa muito obrigado obrigado a bomba